jerry cobb mamey let's go
i'm jerry cobb we're gonna flank them
classic swedish move believes their
trenches
that's fine there we go
jericho zane oh
i saw my first enemy
oh jerry cobb
jury
[Applause]
confirm the kill
jericho they don't know
ah they knew wait med kid
jerry cobb is an excellent medic he's
got this
[ __ ] oh don't kill me bro oh that's just
rude
all right jerry cobb's back i like this
i got four kills there
hi jerry cobb [ __ ]
got em
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god they're all coming out they're
so dumb
war is great i don't know what people
talking about look at all these fools
spawn on me get out of here this is my
spot
all right we're going in for the second
flank there's the tank there's the tank
just lay still just lay still he won't
kill me
just flinch bro just flinch all good
brother i told you i told you
we're gucci my gamers oh i see [ __ ]
oh we shot each other
don't shoot me all right it's time for
carlos
ah jeez luis carlos don't like this
i see you i see you ha ha
headshot oh
[Applause]
i see you
you can lean nice
it's fine i can heal
who shot me for real not cool
we're going in for the flank boys
[Laughter]
oh they don't see me they don't see me
i was just not a kill there we go it's
an eight time baby
oh my god there's so many oh my god what
is happening
oh
i love this [ __ ]
double kill [ __ ] colette baby
bro where are you going no
[ __ ] 15-3 baby let's [ __ ] go
got him
bro don't heal
holy [ __ ]
no they got me i love this game [ __ ]
tyrell man he's the best
i don't think they see me i'm a snake in
the grass dude
sorry bro
stop it oh jesus they don't see the
snake
sorry bro sorry bro
sorry bro mercy kill bro
nothing personal kid
i've got it we're going in with the bomb
no never mind i don't have any bumps
oh jesus oh jesus oh jesus
chicken soup rice [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] just gotta massage my
face and i should be all right
thank you oh you nerd you [ __ ] nerd
[Applause]
no no
uh we join in like not too bad not too
shabby 28 kills i'll take it
stop i forgot to mention the battle of
berlin campaign
is now available since april 23rd
which is next to the invasion of
normandy and battle of moscow check them
out they're cool
as a player you can participate in the
final battle
of world war ii in europe you can change
history
don't do that including conquering and
defending
the inner of berlin if that's something
you would want to do
as well as a reichstag in intense close
quarter city combat
they're really trying to get me canceled
thank you enlisted for sponsoring this
video
check it out it's a fun game getting
sponsored
getting canceled it just goes hand in
hand nowadays
okay here we go this is a video game
it's a game it's a game don't support
history gosh look at these dudes
what all right here we go
my final video guys hope you enjoy it
we're playing as a good blob
my man oh jeez
uh-huh solid-ass fan rolling out
it's not going great not gonna lie but
we got this oh i see a guy
oh they're ours it's all good don't
worry guys
good lub is here feel no fear
can we just yeah okay
here we go
how you doing mate
this is so [ __ ] oh i see the okay now
i see how it works
we want to take this point
there we go it's ours
i know you're welcome guys what's up
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh that guy's having a bad day
oh look they're trying to fight back
[Applause]
idiot
hey stop that good club doesn't like
that
hey guys what's up how are we doing here
the [ __ ] are you doing i got him
[Applause]
nailed it
beg for mercy
head shot okay
that's gonna hurt tomorrow ah shiny
no
no how could you alright dolman
dolmen dolmain
oh we're infantry cool hey guys flank
always go for the flank
yeah [ __ ] germans we're so far off
everyone
me and the boys my squad guys hurry up
can we squeeze through here nice this is
going to be ours dude
nice we're in oh
all right it's our house now [ __ ]
not that i want that or anything
get on [ __ ]
triple kill baby hell yeah
oh [ __ ] no save me
voldemire voldemort we got this
[Applause]
nice voldemort oh [ __ ] ocean
let's go
so okay i'm starting to understand that
you have your squad with you
damn we did fif that's not all right
i'll take it 10 1kb let's go
oh [ __ ] we're the russians
[Applause]
all right squad let's go let's go
where are my people at hey hey oh we're
in goblets v left okay i know this place
all right flank oh let's go for the
flank squad we're going this way
come on squad we got this squad
hurry up you lacey scum
they got a tank [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i threw a nade i mean guys watch
out watch out guys
[Applause]
sorry about that bros oh we're taking
shots we're taking shots
don't shoot my squad
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa everyone chill everyone
chill
damn that guy took out so many people
[ __ ] hell i thought this was russia
not japan
here we go
nice
[Applause]
nice nice
nice multi-kill not bad
nice ow
panda i can't re i can't can you cut me
some slack
and listen oh [ __ ] okay we're good we're
good we still got the squad
how's the squad oh [ __ ] it's just you
and me buddy
how are you holding on oh this
i think we're getting flanked now [ __ ]
let's
move up oh god
they know
sorry guys i lost my no you're still
alive
awesome dude ah dr
simpson maxim it's your time to shine
maxim
ah pull out your knife you'll run faster
everyone knows this
[ __ ] just flank
don't think just flank we got this
[ __ ] we got the last member of the squad
oh god
[Applause]
uh where should we go here okay oh gee
what is this gun
this is not a [ __ ] gun all right
squad come on
[Applause]
ah we no squad don't die don't die help
him
oh he's scared the weak must fear the
strong we must move on
[Applause]
that's the tank
oh [ __ ] we're fine see we're fine
oh here we go here we go epic flank
[Applause]
we're fine i got a med kit
oh [ __ ] watch this
[Applause]
oh god i gotta go
dumb oh god i'm sorry dude i'm sorry
that's [ __ ] up i didn't realize it was
a molotov
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] switch maxim don't die on me now
maxim
peak [ __ ]
ow all right we're going here
oh i see you [ __ ]
oh
[Applause]
i'm shooting everything
i'm fine gosh we're third baby
guys be careful don't pull in squad
squad
squad no squad no squad
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] squad [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh ow we all right squad's fine
i'm way too into this this is ridiculous
we're pushing up squad
[Applause]
i [ __ ] saw him all my squad members
are dead dude
what the [ __ ] where are they
oh from above no way legit enjoying this
super cool
sorry bro you're pretty dead
oh god
i got the perfect spot
oh bro sorry bro
it's not camping it's glam
i don't know sorry look at these [ __ ]
oh my god they keep pushing in but they
never see me
nice
this is ridiculous no no no police
swedish i'm swedish gunny
oh i wasn't russian come on
oh i was doing so well there
[Music]
she
go i really like this game
yo best bomber i've always thought i was
thank you ah sh i say
sally oh hello germans have weird taste
that's all i got to say
there you are guys come on
how do we flank him we're in the wrong
spot aren't we
oh we're capturing this all right let's
do it squad yeah hell yeah
okay we got it here we go
sorry bro
[Applause]
sorry bro oh [ __ ] there's so many
sorry bros
nothing personal kiddo
oh he just healed sorry
don't ever roll up on me and my squad
again right squad
ah scheisse oh how hell yeah
people say war is bad but i mean
all right not on my watch we're climbing
in
no no no what they should
oh gosh are there people here
oh no [ __ ] open that up
this map is super [ __ ] cool
don't think so [ __ ] all right squad
let's roll up
hold up there we go 10 for that
let's go squad let's take this [ __ ] bro
don't stand there by the door bro
here we go now we take echo
someone's definitely shooting at me oh
[ __ ]
multi-kill baby
oh [ __ ]
oh i hear them oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
sorry bro
bro oh bro
i'm out of ammo oh gosh
oh that would have been safe oh my god
i'm alive
there's fools
oh my gosh boom
i got him they take so long to explode
come on herman
we're killing this game number one baby
let's go
[Applause]
i see you [ __ ]
ow guys chill stop bombing me
[Applause]
jesus christ so many people dying
no sorry i got my swan
oh hello
big beg
[Music]
love this game love it
ah so close i wasted time on that stupid
tank
anyway guys if you use the link in
description this game is free to check
out i recommend it it's out on windows
playstation 5
xbox x you also get thanks to me you're
welcome three days premium which is
awesome
silver order for troops and silver order
for weapons so take advantage now check
it out if you want to it's a fun game
thank you gaijin games for sponsoring
this video thank you for like cancelling
me
that is all see you tomorrow bro fist